[Music]
hello and welcome to the android
fireside chat another addition of this
thing you will notice that there are a
lot of people on stage up here this is
probably the most they have for any
session ever a taya
in fact it's so many they were in danger
of violating the fire code we may need
to ask the audience to leave we're going
to do a seriously quick introduction of
the people on stage so you get an idea
of a who they are be more importantly
what they actually do and what answers
they may actually be able to provide
starting with me I'm just the MT I don't
matter I'm Chet Brian go Brian curls
from programming languages Java C was
awesome Colin Wahle a Windows and
activities Rashaad Android media tour
Norby Android studio whole monkey
graphics xavier aldehyde give it up a
tutors Dan Sandler system UI Rachel garb
user experience Ben poise framework
Rakeem Abad I placed our app and
entering the snaps
tahm Kench android support library
Nespresso challenge in Android security
good Murray Android performance Steph
cut person Android IDs and frameworks
Dave Burke pure Android overhead eat boy
architecture components I'm a guest here
I'm from jetbrains I'm CEO if you're
French Maxime says here
Adam Powell framework Mike Lauren lesser
Android overhead at Bank a Florian
manage the framework team all right so
everybody got that
excellent moving on we have a few slides
to cover a little bit of content before
we get into the meat of it so oh no
actually let's just get into it so
here's the way it works I'll ask a
couple so you understand what this is
you're going to ask questions and we're
going to we may have aid the answers we
don't know it depends on what you ask
the ground rule is we don't really talk
about no we don't talk about futures so
if you say yeah but what is Google gonna
do you know a year from now on this
thing then we will say thank you for the
question with somebody else like to ask
one just so you know when we say that
there's a reason but I will show you how
this works for a couple of things so we
trolled Twitter and G+ to get some
questions sort of pre-roll some topics
just to find out what the community
would like to know about people who
weren't necessarily here one of the
things that came up I will summarize the
several comments and Twitter that
essentially came down to what about
adopting Collin as a language for
Android check done
[Applause]
alright here's another one that came up
a few different comments phrased in
different ways but essentially boils
down to a two-part question how does
fuchsia relate to Android Dave how do
you spell fuchsia and fuchsia is
early-stage experimental project we you
know we actually have lots of cool early
projects at Google I think what's
interesting here is it's open source so
people can see it and comment on it like
lots of early-stage projects it's going
to probably pivot and morph there's some
really smart people on it people we've
worked with who are great and so I was
kind of excited to see what happens but
it's definitely different independent
project to Android yeah basically it
thank you so kay we're going to ask
another question here but we could
actually multi-process this thing people
should be lining up at the mics if they
want to ant ask questions and if nobody
wants to ask questions find by us the
session will end very early so second
part of two-part question for Mike
how does flutter relate to Android well
let's see we have pretty much the entire
Android team what do you all think is
the best framework for Android is it
Android yeah so we kind of like our own
stuff but the Android has always been
pretty open as our core principle so the
better answer is use whatever works for
you we try to make stuff that works for
you we hope you like it we hope you use
it if you do that's great if you find
something that you like better
then that gives us something to shoot
for all right we have people at the mics
now so why don't we go to a mic over on
the left there
great question I think one of the things
we made clear in the keynote and we are
trying to say very clearly is we are
embracing Kotlin someone can hug max
there if you want yeah hug max we're
bracing Kotlin embrace but we're also
doubling down simultaneously on our
existing languages and we were very open
about that in the keynote with
investments in for instance Java eight
language features lambdas are my
personal favorite in the Java C compiler
we also made extensive and improvements
in api's again the Java time API is my
personal favorite and there was a
phalanx of improvements there we also
made extensive improvements in C++ and
you'll continue to see investment in
Kotlin and also investment in our
existing programming languages in fact
very specifically Dave has increased the
size of the teams in all of those areas
so it's not an either/or for us it truly
is an and so we really do believe that
for developers who want to stay with the
Java programming language it is a
wonderful language I've told people when
I studied CSS Brown was the first
language that I learned and it is
wonderful that said for those who would
like to try Kotlin it is quite a
beautiful language and a lot of us here
have tried it and think it's quite
wonderful so if I could rephrase that
was either one should work but look did
I catch the essence of that you could
try either one yeah okay I'm sorry you
want to find some more words for that
well you could go ahead go ahead go
ahead a good thing they cut me off in
the keynote huh all right I think we got
it thank you let's go over there
[Music]
we could turn it on under your friends
devices otherwise so to be perfectly
honest like we're not on those teams so
that's why we're kind of looking at each
other we do really think that privacy is
a control that you should have and you
still have that in all these services I
think you're asking for those teams to
support the new services they're
introducing and then not require
location of things part of what makes
those features good is to use those
services if they're having a chat of
their own like this I would ask you to
ask them but we are ensuring that you
always have the choice it may not be the
choice that you necessarily want of you
know fine grained choices within but we
do think you should have the visibility
to know what's on and have a control in
the OS to turn it on or turn it off
thanks you sir
yeah so I actually did have project
travel as part of my keynote but we can
have enough time number one number two
is it's a very device manufacturer
focused project and so we thought we
might bore you all a little bit but
since you've asked I can for you now
bring up the teleprompter no I'm joking
yeah so project travel actually if you
ask a lot of people around here who
worked on it they'll tell you it was a
huge amount of work and they're still
angry at me Rashaad is nodding his head
he's like so pissed off because the
amount of work that went into media
framework was huge but basically what we
did was we created a foundation layer to
Android a very formal we call vendor
interface and it's analogous to the
developer API so today we have a
developer API we have CTF tests have
tested the idea being you write an
application that runs on any hardware
we've introduced a new vendor interface
at the bottom
everything south of the vendor interface
is Silicon specific and hardware
specific and then we have VTS tests that
test that vendor interface so the idea
is when the P release comes along
through a device maker you take P and it
will run on top of your vendor
implementation from today's odof ice
that you build SE and the whole reason
for that is we want to make it easier
and faster for device makers to update
devices because if it's faster they'll
get updates that more quickly if it cost
less they'll do more updates so that's
the whole premise of it it's a huge huge
change with very formal
err I can talk about it more but you
know one of the things that kind of it's
kind of analogous to Kotlin like with
Colin like last year somebody grabbed
the mic and said hey we have Kotlin and
Evan put their hands up and so we gave
you Kotlin treble you ask we deliver a
cup not really a 4/4 treble it was
actually the silicon vendors and the
device makers who were asking us I had
already reduced the cost because today
when you build its Android device a lot
of the silicon and device specific code
is intermixed with a framework and the
core OS and then every time we change
the operating system they have to rework
that code and so you know they asked us
and if we make it better and so we came
up with with trouble but yeah it's a
huge change probably the biggest we
architected of Android since it started
it was an enormous amount of work and
thank you to all my colleagues who hate
me for implementing it so yes so Sudeste
it was a huge amount of work I just want
to make sure you understand there's a
lot of engineers at Google we are not
here today they're not a oh they have
been working incredibly hard they had to
go through like millions of lines of
code touch lines of code that never seen
before one guy on my team like I think
almost lost it working on this so you
should share them because it's a huge
amount of what you'll never seen API
you'll never see tools but is going to
make Android better in the future
we tried to bring any more engineers up
on stage the producers would have killed
us so there was a follow-up question
about treble in Twitter on Twitter so I
was going to ask that one which was the
dockside the treble on device is
launched with oh but DP one running with
treble on existing devices okay that
wasn't a complete sentence but this is
Twitter so that question is will devices
that get updated to also get treble
right so so one of the challenges of
doing this hugely architecture is that
if we did it sort of blindly we've
actually slowed down an adoption - oh I
think it'd be a lot of work to do and so
we wanted to try not to slow down the
short term to speed up in the long term
so if you have an existing device using
a device maker on N and you want to
update - oh the travel requirements
aren't applied to you however if you're
a new device if you're a device maker
building a new device then you have to
comply to the ole architecture so that's
sort of how it works and then what we
did just to prove it all out was we
decided to treat the 2016 pixel as a new
device for oh and so this is fully what
we call treble eyes which means that all
of that vendor implementation is is
implemented in a separate process and
it's built like you would rebuild we
basically rebuilt the system on pixel
and we did that because we wanted to
prove it and to end so that devices are
coming later in the year new devices I
know we'll be able to sail plainly
through
I have one I really hate the colors but
I'm fixing this in oh and I really hate
notifications some that come from
nameless applications from my own
company and that gentleman over there
along with members of this team are
fixing that this time with notification
channels I I really hate the lock
contention and system server so we'll
fix after than actually seriously I
obsessive that while contention
assistant server bugs me anyone else
have a confession I go what this group
should know that battery life and the
reason we don't break it it's because
all of you we have to mesh the keeping
you alive but keeping better like alive
at the same time alright that'll do for
a sample how about over here
um you know that really depends on you
know I don't I don't regret the stuff we
did and I think you always make
improvements but you know it's you're
looking for things I would change
probably the big things is like step
that we did that allow the applications
to do too much like a big one for me is
the Settings provider access allowing
applications to take change system
settings I wish we had never done that
and you know just made sure we had clear
controlled api's for them to do things
so those are the kind of things that
they're really hard after the fact once
applications start doing things to try
to get them back under control and
they'll talk the main things I think I
wish we just you know click places of
wish we've done better apps like
well I mean that amantha thing is that's
not really about users that that's about
developers and there's a lot of things
that we don't allow applications to do
because it's better for the overall
device behavior and actually you know FS
repeats fevers is actually one of the
things that some speaking of things we
regret doing I think if I had done again
like having that be so easy to make
things that you can launch applications
like that was clearly a big mistake that
we made and we didn't really at the time
realize that once it's there and you
have like 100 applications on your phone
all listening to this broadcast the kind
of like hell that's going to break loose
on the device when that happens so I
really think that's that's something
that we need to like to really put
brakes on and get control back over the
device and switch the more controlled
things like job scheduler and if I could
add to that on user choice you know we
announced I hope we announce that we
have two billion users if not I just
announced it
and that's a reasonable fraction of the
world's population and so we think about
literally everyone when we're designing
it and there's a lot of questions and
it's just really hard to put in front of
users and expect them to make scalable
decisions especially when applications
put something in their face that says
you know hey just please turn this on
it'll make this feature better and it's
not the applications are doing anything
wrong usually as their individual choice
but if a hundred applications all asks
the same thing and the user says well I
said yes to the first 70 I'll say yes to
the next 30 then they end up with an
unusable device so we have to balance
user choice which you're right that is
one of our core principles we have to
balance that with making devices that
like literally anyone can administer and
manage and still have a good experience
I can add more to that too because on
top of that they're you know there is
user choice you can like say I want to
if you really want to listening things
going on do a foreground service and the
user knows that you're running all the
time now and I think that part of this
is actually having the user choice being
like clear to the user you know it's
like it's clear to the users like oh
this application is like just running it
all the time because I really care about
so it's okay with me and I will lead to
do that versus like subtleties about
like well okay I have this choice to
allow it to run sometimes in the
background but I don't really know what
that does and I don't realize that when
I do this a lot with a lot of
applications that actually there's a lot
of stuff going on the background not
aware of so I think it's you know we we
learned it like with the list foreground
services they're having that UI and
having like these kind of clear lock
things you go into like oh I've decided
this so this has a lot of input you know
implications of what you do that the
user understands all that stuff together
as that's a good you know they can make
that choice between those things but
having kind of subtle choices about like
this or that and it's not really clear
what it means really doesn't leave the
user with much choice so they don't
really understand I think that finally
that kind of shows another principle
that's coming to the forefront in more
recent versions of Android which is that
when the user makes a choice we want to
make sure that their choice to allow the
app to do something we want to make sure
that that's something that the user can
actually see the effects of and make
sure that they can kind of audit that
behavior as they use the device so I
think that if I am said the foreground
service notification really does kind of
provide that visibility when an app is
running in the background Thanks a
little different topic so we'll take one
from online for Rachel I believe is
material design done or do you see it
growing and evolving the work is never
done with design and I think that you
probably have a lot of other things
other patterns that you would like to
see and have supported for your apps so
the material team they're growing and
they're investing heavily in this space
this was an offshoot of Android the
material team started out very small in
Android and and then it grew so big that
it is a completely different department
so yeah I don't think they're sitting
around twiddling their thumbs they're
definitely doing a lot to evolve the
language designers design and in
particular they just launched a bunch of
code one of the great things about
having a separate department for
material is that they have now the
capacity to bring on
more prototypers more software engineers
so if you go to material yo you'll see
that they've got a bunch of new
components available for various
different platforms to make it easier to
integrate the stuff that has evolved in
material over the last couple of years
so I think you can look at their work
product along a number of different axes
and see the material design is alive and
well and continuing to evolve and to see
all that stuff you go to material dot IO
lots of good stuff there resources tools
good articles thanks about there you
mean to build to write green files yeah
yeah we do plan to support it as soon as
it's finished on the grader side Thanks
but here
[Music]
no I don't think so
next so cotton has some kind of a
standard library which is about six
hundred kilobytes so that's the only
thing you need to add
cage fight so systrace gets all of its
data from the linux kernel it doesn't
really do anything with your application
directly it's not going to go and see
what functions take a long time or
anything like that it's just going to
say hey your app was running here and
then it stopped running here
that's all it knows the CPU profiler in
android studio on the other hand will
actually sample the runtime of your
application and tell you hey you're
spending 50 milliseconds in this
function and 4 milliseconds in this
function and things like that that means
that the CPU profiler has higher
overhead which means it can perturb the
results of your performance testing but
it gives you greater visibility into
your application so my general
recommendation would be use systrace to
get a general idea of how your
application runs because you will
probably spot a lot of problems there
once you have some idea of what's taking
too long
you can use the CPU profiler to get a
closer look inside your application
great thanks tor did that cover it that
sounds good
no rebuttal yeah I mean the CPU profiler
has a low overhead mode until you start
recording actual sampling so you can use
it initially as well but systrace
obviously does more whole system tracing
right thanks well I believe we have not
heard much about data binding this week
and I wonder if that if that's still a
technology which would be continued to
adopt eat yes actually
so with architecture components we
shipped that sample application that
uses data mining so we're still working
on that
tools are still working on that right
tor yes
no we should we have a lot of other
things working on two-bit data binding
is one of our responsibilities thank you
thank you yes hi I started writing
Kotlin last week and I felt that it felt
oddly familiar and I thought that's
because I spent the last year doing code
reviews of our iOS developer and Swift
so I was wondering if you could comment
on the relationship between Kotlin and
Swift we are independent there is a lot
of resemblance I guess because there we
are aiming for the same task to be to
make a productive developers
yeah I might conceptually thank you Max
is quite modest he actually was one of
the key folks who contributed the
language andrey breslav is probably here
now also very very significant in the
lead language designer I talk too much
don't I
the that one fact that Dave and I were
just talking about as Kotlin does
predates Swift in fact they first
announcement about Colin was in 2011 and
the first release was in 2012 the
languages of all since then so it's just
an interesting fact good to know thanks
hello so I personally think that being
open and open-source is one of the most
important powers of Android and one of
the most important announcements for me
this week was that the firebase SDKs are
being open sourced and it
unfortunately Android SDK is not
currently but will follow so the
question is what about Google Play
services is there a plan to because five
days Android SDK and the Play services
are so integrated so firebase can be
open source now but why not Play
services I think the thing about Play
services is it's there's lots of stuff
in there some of it is developer focused
and some of it is just really extension
of applications like Google's own
applications and so sort of Google
policy with their applications as
they're just not open sourced the
challenge is there's no easy way in GMS
quarters sort of say hey this is a
developer component - this is a
extension of an app component so yeah
also we don't have anyone from the GMs
core or the Play services team here so I
can punt the question we punt the
questions to you so if you're going to
put the question I don't know what to do
with it I'll go into an infinite loop
moving on moving on all right let me go
to a theoretical thing what's the one
piece of advice you would like
developers to never ever follow when
making Android apps anybody force
garbage collection I don't know
thread that sleep in the ondraw method
No okay give it another education
context for everything okay moving on
you hi so we saw the introduction at i/o
of a bunch of really great new
performance profiling tools for example
for network and for CPU one thing that's
still kind of missing is a good battery
profiler for our applications we do have
battery stats and battery historian but
they're extremely difficult to use and
to interpret the results from and I was
wondering if battery profiling for our
apps is something that we might be able
to look forward to I think yes so if
it's a very good question and the one of
the things we talked about was that the
battery profiling really has to be based
on CPU and a network you want to look at
those two things as a really important
input and so we felt like it was
important to do CPU and networks first
so those are our initial profilers we
don't we don't talk about features but I
will say that we get a lot of questions
about battery profiling so so you can
read that however you want that that's
code for staff and team are working on
it
so a rush do you know about the play
dashboard stuff that was going on
wasn't battery one of the stats that
we're talking about there I a so we're
going to start showing a system health
information within the play console and
the team has been hard to work at this
and it's going to glued everything from
crashes to memory usage - is that right
Ben's battery what we put out there was
stuck wakelocks
which is a big battery in the system the
number of wake-ups that are happening in
your application and then also
information about janky frames so if the
application is running and it's really
high GPU intensive you'll get
information about that to fix those
issues both of the very short jank
events and the really severe horrible
jank events that we named after our
vice-president behind us that we call
internally at Devi and I'm glad I found
an opportunity to talk about it so thank
you so much for that question you're
famous yeah hi i'm steven from
xda-developers and i have a fault a
question about treble so we're very
excited about treble the whole how it
can help make it easier to upgrade to
new versions but the most exciting part
for us is the mention of more work on
open sourcing hardware drivers is the
work that Google can be doing mostly
focused on the existing projects like
Ford Reno and Lima or you can be working
more to start new projects with the
biggest inventors and get their code
open source and we've been just focused
on the architecture I mean that that's
really up to the silicon vendors and the
device makers so we just wanted to make
sure we had a much nicer architecture we
haven't really put thought into that
specific aspect of it thank you thanks
all right hey everyone
so last year at i/o there was a really
excellent session on attention and
notifications and treating people well I
was wondering so since we saw that
manifest this year through notification
channels and through attention based
notification sorting are there any other
issues like that on the platform that
you
are near and dear to your heart that you
wish developers kind of spent more time
thinking about why applications need
permissions we get that a lot internally
about ideal on those they understand the
premise but not necessarily what the
entire application is doing with that
data and so that's something that I
would love to see developers take a lot
of care about asking in context and we
found when they didn't contact users
understand better why they're giving you
something they're more inclined to give
it to you if the answer or the context
is good and they understand the value so
always put a lot of time into that
because users appreciate it and I'd
broaden that even more to settings in
general we know from foundational
research that users get pretty
overwhelmed by the number of settings
and being able to find what they need at
the moment that they need it so you know
apps should really think about every
single setting that they want to
introduce and is it really necessary can
a smart choice be made that will satisfy
a majority of the users we think about
that too in the platform level and we
have to keep thinking about that it gets
more complicated over time and every new
feature every new setting every new
thing we add to Android stands the top
ten things we didn't add as it's it's a
huge part of how we design things and
how we want to encourage apps to do
things and honestly every year we add
new stuff we've probably already just
launched the stuff that users are going
to find terrible and then we're going to
come back and fix next year so we keep
ourselves in business all that on so I
think apk size is another one a lot of
our users given our global footprint
have you know lower end devices and I
think you know those might not always be
that the users that modifies the best
but they also can't afford to upgrade so
I think it's really important as a
developer community that we kind of band
together and really improve our apps on
those low-end devices both from an API
standpoint and from a rare music
standpoint
I'm going to put words in Tim's mouth
and say that he wants everyone to care
more about performance as well so some
of the stuff some of the sessions here
so as well as some of the tools that
we're talking about are coming out
because we want it to be easier for
developers to actually chase that
information so that they can fix it for
users am I allowed to provide an answer
somebody else like to say that instead
they're good all right okay you hi I get
the sense that you guys really like
Kotlin a lot and I'm wondering if you
have any future plans to implement
platform framework components using
taut-line and if so would you expose SDK
API well as has been said we are also
committed to Java and just pragmatically
the bazillion lines of code that we
already have in Java so I think as much
as we love it the reality is we're
probably going to be continuing to
produce Java code for the near future at
the point where we're starting to
introduce new features in Kotlin it's
going to be something that we make sure
is 100% compatible with Java programming
language too so it's going to be
something that's going to take us a
while to adopt internally the first
thing they'll probably see from us is
that we'll make sure that our java
programming language API is the legacy
ones that we already have and the new
ones that we create interoperate
perfectly with Colin so that's going to
be a goal from us starting from now
going forward I should clarify that
bazillion lines of code was just an
estimate actually far more technically
one point zero three six bazillion thank
you Thanks hi yesterday I went to a talk
about a progressive web apps and these
guys are really catching up so should I
list my time learning JavaScript or
codling so cockiness of JavaScript
back-end you can write cutting the
compass to JavaScript so you can do both
my bidet take a stab at it so I think
the way to think about the PWA is
progressive web apps is really if your
company is already focused on building a
flagship product on mobile web I think
you know it's unrealistic for you to go
and say pivot that entire team to go and
focus on app development obviously
everyone on this page here is an Android
diehard and we're really focused on
improving the Whoopie SDK in the
operating system and what we want to do
is say if you're really focused on
building a you know a native app
experience and you know you believe
that's where it converts best for your
users then we want to make it as easy as
possible for you to get those users onto
your app experience both from a
developer standpoint and from a
reachability standpoint okay thanks what
are some great new things you think have
been overlooked or we're left out of Io
this year for some reason
so what are things that we decided to
not talk about that we would talk about
now yeah everything is it well I mean I
mean the biggest one is project travel
like that is like enormous well we
talked about downloadable fonts emoji
that's kind of cool yep talk about that
yep talk about it again but yeah we did
we talked about the garbage collector
that it went down from tomorrow coin
session and garbage well I'm going to
steal it's under if I mention it how
cool it is
how fast it is did you know that we used
to only garbage collect when processes
were in the background but that of it's
so fast we garbage collect in the
foreground
super cool but I am stealing Brian
Thunder so stuff now and also Dex code
layers we talked about that that's why
your Thunder being stolen
okay so I'll stop - stealing it's done
there you should go to the art talk
tomorrow's cool stuff I have a hard time
believing you guys fit everything into
ball your presentations yeah um so our
app is localized in about 50 languages
and we also have a lot of resources that
are localized as well is there any
thought around being able to
conditionally download those resources
as opposed to addressing them all in one
massive resource definition I'm
representative of a smaller out
basically yeah Google definitely has
that problem with their apps and it's
something we're aware of there's I'm not
going to talk about future stuff there
is a split apks that we introduced in
the platform and l that's not being used
yet and we are kind of setting up to to
address that problem but nothing right
now I have an answer for the previous
question and something my team did that
should have thought about it
updatable graphics drivers we now you
know have the ability to update the
graphics drivers from the Play Store now
[Applause]
we have time for one more question okay
is volley still a recommended networking
solution my guess is not here can we say
no so in the architecture components
will come and using retrofits we already
Zork HTTP that's what we say also also
if you are doing image loading we think
light is a very nice library but these
are recommendations that's it good
thanks we did have one more important
question online and then we'll close it
down it was my app crashes with no
pointer exception when the user rotates
the phone while a network request is
happening do you have any plans to fix
yes thank you
you
[Music]